All right, Katherine.
This is lesson one.
This is lesson two.
We've been done with lesson one for
a while.
>> Yeah.
>> And we did the Happy Birthday
app here, remember?
>> Yeah.
>> And in lesson two,
we started to make the Just Java app.
>> Yeah, the coffee ordering app.
>> So our learner has traversed this
long, arduous journey and is right here.
>> At the beginning of lesson three.
>> Right.
>> And
this is where we need to keep
working on the coffee ordering app.
>> Okay.
So before we talk
about that let's just move
all of this aside, so
we can focus on lesson three
a little bit better, yeah?
>> Sounds good.
>> So I'm just going to drag
all of these around here.
>> I'll move this there,
I'll move this here.
Here's lesson three.
>> Okay, how many big ideas
are there in lesson three?
>> I think we can do four big parts.
>> Okay, let's just split
these into four piles then.
There Okay.
>> There is is.
And what are these ideas?
>> The first one of its methods.
>> Methods?
Okay Well let's begin here then.
>> Here's a look at the different
stages of the app for this lesson.
We'll start by adding an order
summary section to the app and
understand how methods in Java can
help us write more efficient code.
Later, we will add a checkbox for
a topping,
like whipped cream,
to add to our coffee.
However, we'll need to understand
object-oriented programming
to determine the state of the checkbox,
whether the user checked it or
not, and include that information
in the order summary.
Within our app, object-oriented
programming allows us to dynamically
interact with views, so that we can
read this state from the views, and
then change the contents of other views,
while the app is running.
We'll add another checkbox for
the chocolate topping and
then we'll add a text field, so
that we can ask the user for their name.
Again, we'll write Java code to read
in the user input from this field and
then display it in the order summary.
We'll also learn about
control flow statements,
particularly something called
if/else statements, so
that our app has different behavior,
based on certain conditions.
Basically by looking at what
toppings the user wants,
we'll be able to adjust the price per
cup of coffee either by $1 or $2.
Now the order summary is not that
useful, if it never leaves the app.
So we'll learn about intents in Android,
so that when the user hits the Order
button, we can send the order summary
out to an email app like this.
Then you can specify a specific
email address to send it to.
We'll end the lesson by covering
more topics on Android resources,
learning about how to support different
languages in the app such as Spanish.
We'll also experiment with changing
the styles and theme of the app.
For example,
you can change the color of the app bar
by customizing the theme of the app.
There's a lot to cover,
so let's get started.